on ne peut pas encore parler d'erreur
judiciaire mais fait rarissime on
s'achemine vers une révision de la
condamnation de patrick dils en janvier
89 la cour d'assises de la moselle le
condamné à la perpétuité pour le meurtre
de deux enfants aujourd'hui alors qu'il
a déjà purgé 12 ans de prison
le parquet général s'est déclaré
favorable à la révision de son procès
clément weill-raynal myriam métaoui
depuis que son fils patrick est en
prison jacqueline revient parfois le
long de cette voie ferrée ou deux petits
garçons de 8 ans tu retrouvé assassiné
en 1986
quelques mois plus tard les enquêteurs
arrêtèrent patrie un adolescent alors
âgé de 17 ans qui avoue a le double
meurtre avant de se rétracter
des aveux auquel n'ont jamais cru ses
parents ben ouais ça c'est comme je vous
dis moi on lui a pas donné à manger ni à
boire relais der garde à vue il va
certes on m'a dit si tu lui dis que
c'est toi tu verras tu es parents et or
à manger à boire d'après moi c'est ça
quand on est jeune la chambre de patrick
est resté tel quel était le jour de son
arrestation une chambre d'adolescent
patrick a aujourd'hui 30 ans et a passé
la moitié de sa vie en prison
mais il ya un an un fait nouveau est
capital a été porté à la connaissance
des enquêteurs francis heaulme le tueur
en série déjà plusieurs fois condamné
vivait à l'époque du drame à proximité
du lieu où les corps des deux enfants
ont été retrouvés
une révélation qui a incité l'avocat de
la famille d'ilan a déposé une requête
en révision
on espère qu'il sera blanchi douze ans
après oui il serait resté douze ans pour
rien en prison oui bien sûr il y a les
aveux mais patrick avait à l'époque 17
ans il vivait en famille à proximité de
la voie ferrée
des voisins ont affirmé l'avoir aperçu
dans la rue le jour du meurtre
un dossier bien fragile compte tenu de
la révélation de
présence de francis heaulme sur les
lieux du crime c'est ce qui a motivé cet
après midi le réquisitoire de l'avocat
général de la cour de cassation qui
s'est déclaré favorable à une révision
du procès patrick est aujourd'hui
toujours détenu à la prison de toul
il saura le 21 juin prochain si la
justice décide ou non de le remettre en
liberté